hey guys so today we're going to be
doing a nice little random unboxing like
i don't even know what is in this little
surprise
bubble wrap here i got this little treat
from nomad and i'm such a huge fan of
nomad i love everything that they have
they've got iphone cases they have some
really cool charging dock they're gonna
have like mouse pads they've got like
leather cases for your freaking macbooks
like oh my god like their stuff is just
it's super high quality which is why i
love it and today we've got a little a
little package here i haven't actually
seen what's in here yet so i have no
idea i just took it out of the box
because it was trash day and i needed to
get my recycling out so one of the
things that i struggle with is being an
unboxer and a tech reviewer like we have
a lot of perks like we get a lot of
things but with a lot of things comes a
lot of recycling and breaking down boxes
especially when you only have like once
a week recycling is a lot so let's see
what we've got in here thank you nomad
for sending this over always so excited
to see what you guys have got i also
have to be extra careful with knives now
because i'm on blood thinners and my
sister has been opening my packages the
one day that she didn't open something i
got myself on the freaking box and i was
like um i gotta be careful because i
don't want to bleed out
okay what we got
a little grab bag here this is
exciting what have we got
oh gee oh wow oh my goodness gifts
galore it's been a while since i've just
done like a random unboxing for fun like
this is this is great all right we've
got we have a pen oh my god okay
look i'm sure all of this is great but
uh the other day i had a sign for
package and this happened a few times
already the guy was like okay would you
have a pen i was like i don't think i i
have a pen i looked all over the house
could not find a pen the only thing that
i had was like a glitter sharpie marker
and so i had to like sign for that and
he was like you have to have you have to
have something in this place i was like
dude you all know me i don't have a pen
and now i do have a pen the only other
pen that i did find was
it was a tactical pen which is not
really made for writing it's
made for other things so
um
that didn't
right we have a pen i want that guy to
come back
and it looks like we have oh
these are mag safe okay so the k oh this
is so exciting because
what oh my gosh this is this is so
exciting because this is actually what i
have been using bedside is this little
charging dock but this is magsafe which
is very exciting because the one that i
had previous was the nomad charging kind
of like little leather base that you
kind of just set it on wasn't mag safe
you just kind of had to you know place
it ever so slightly but this is freaking
beautiful and is this an iphone stand oh
my god this is great
for my desk this is oh these are so
awesome oh and look at this a little 30
watt usb seat this is a
this is a good gift
because i don't have a pen
look at that look at this pen look at
this oh my god it's so heavy it has such
a nice weight to it is this recording
yeah
great should i zoom in a little yeah we
can do that look at that that's nice
check this pen out
let's see if it writes
that's not a good demo i need a piece of
paper okay well it's writing on my hand
oh that's nice look at that oh man now
i'm gonna have writing on my hand for
the rest of the videos that i'm shooting
today oops but here you go look at that
a nice write hyped about the pen okay
pen
check can't believe i have a writing
utensil now i know so let's go from
smallest to largest so next we have this
uh 30 watt usbc
power adapter i was actually just
looking for one of these to plug that
camera in oh look at that it just goes
like this surprise nice look at that
that's beautiful that's beautiful
oh
where did you even go look at that
very
very nice
great product very into it i also love
this look at their little skew that they
have here there's like a little car
driving on it it's so cute but look at
my art should i sell that as an nft
that's art that's art next we have the
base one with magsafe so this is a 15
watt mag safe fast charging weighted
design for convenience solid metal body
with glass face wow
this is oh my god it's so heavy
but like
it's freaking beautiful
shiny
shimmering
splendid oh okay i see why they gave us
the
sent this separate because you need this
to charge this so this doesn't come with
a power brick so obviously you're gonna
need to have one of those um sold
separately or you can use one that you
already have i love this braided cable
though this is very very nice oh it's
long too that's that's great so we just
plug this in just like so and this plugs
into the back i love that it's weighted
too so yeah that's a nice look i'm not
plugging it in because i don't feel like
getting up again but that's on there
that's great wow i love magsafe
very premium that is a premium product
if i've ever seen one all right okay
what do we have next
magsafe mounted stand
yeah check that out
wow
that looks so sleek oh my god i love it
so much so that looks like integrated
magsafe mount that apple sells so you
just have that already
assuming that you have that so don't buy
this thinking that that's coming with it
because you'll be
a little a little disappointed
thinking that it comes with it so here
is your little mag safe connector and
this stand obviously is made for the
magsafe connectors if you already have
one of these you're definitely going to
need that to make this work so you're
just going to slide cable right through
here just like so that just pops in just
like that this is freaking beautiful i
love this so much so if you can see the
cord just goes right through the back
and then you would just plug this into
your apple charger that you already have
i love it like look how nice this looks
beautiful
absolutely beautiful
last up is the base one max with magsafe
this is definitely going by my bedside
very excited about this
i also like that it is a nice
fresh white color too like that looks
really good oh this looks so nice oh
wow
look at that
so heavy too
like this isn't just some little tiny
flimsy
device like this is freaking industrial
look at that this is so beautiful
i mean i haven't tried every single
magsafe charging dock in existence but
to date i don't think i've seen one
that's nice like this is by far the
nicest one that i've ever seen by the
quality and just like the feel like this
is so it's perfect it's so beautiful put
the apple watch
just like so i also love that it has
this nice braided white cable too to
match just plugs right there into the
back
you are magsafe ready for charging well
thank you guys for watching and huge
thank you to nomad for sending me these
to check out they're always sending me
so many goodies and i haven't really
made a video about them in a long time
so i really wanted to share with you the
latest nomad haul and i'm so glad i
decided to do this because i had no idea
it was in this package i was like let's
just see what's here let's do a fun
little unboxing and these are so good i
just can't believe it i'm so excited to
have some new charging docks around the
house and to go do a little upgrade to
see how everything looks in their new
homes so i will see you guys in my next
video let me know if there's anything
else you'd like to see me unbox or check
out here on my channel leave me some
comments below and let me know what you
guys think of these and which one is
your favorite i'll see you guys in the
next video don't forget to subscribe hit
the bell to be notified when i post new
videos and leave me some comments below
so that we can all chat together i'll
see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]
you